oh Reddit a veritable hellscape of
misinformation designed to confuse
confound discourage disheartened and
deeply depress us all falling down the
proverbial Reddit rabbit hole is its own
unique brand of torture especially the
threads in the dark diet culture web so
when I tumbled into the Reddit thread
titled skinny people habits that
featured over 700 comments I knew we
needed to talk hey everyone I'm Abby
sharp welcome to Abby's kitchen
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
don't forget to check out my disclaimer
in the description and hit up that
description as well for my free Hunger
cushion combo ebook so I was actually
inspired to do this video after I was on
Tick Tock and I saw a fellow die culture
commentator gal Raphael
um she was sharing kind of what these
skinny Reddit users were eating in a day
and I listened to them and I thought
yeah we should probably unpack this now
please note that skinny people is not my
preferred verbiage but I'm gonna use it
anyway because hey dye culture is
unfortunately our culture and this is
the language that the internet chooses
to use so I'm not going to censor that
out I'm also not I repeat not
encouraging anyone to become or aspire
to be skinny chances are you've seen a
lot of these skinny person observations
floating around AKA things that others
notice that folks in smaller bodies just
tend to do and my job here is to help
you understand if these tips or
observations are potential signs of a
dysfunction Channel or a healthy
relationship with food in a safe science
grounded space whether or not they make
a person skinny is in most cases a moot
point to me but let's dive into these
observations while I make my kids and
myself a little chickpea cookie dough
all right observation number one they
socialize by burning calories not
consuming them my skinny friend would
suggest meeting up for a walk rather
than for coffee or drinks I've come to
love this and I try to do it as much as
possible socializing doesn't have to
mean consuming calories as I drink my
coffee I actually kind of love this I
feel like turning walking into a hangout
actually creates a really positive
association with Movement by making it a
more enjoyable sustainable activity that
we see as fun rather than as punishment
or something that we have to do to burn
calories he's a freak he's a fast girl
calories which make
condense but it also helps to Boost
energy improve our mood and improve
sleep and our circadian rhythm now I
don't want to create fear around going
to dinner with friends because at the
end of the day we all need to eat and as
we'll get to skinny people they go out
for dinner with friends too but social
isolation is probably one of the biggest
challenges that people face when trying
to meet health or body goals and it's a
major reason why people just don't
usually stick to their plan and unlike
so many other kind of weight loss hacks
you're not really losing out on what
actually matters which in this case is
the experience of socializing so to me
this is like a win-win all around and
speaking of social Hangouts observation
number two is taking leftovers home from
restaurants so she began to realize that
her thinner friend never finished her
meals when they went out she would take
the leftovers for another meal or leave
some food on her plate that she wasn't
hungry enough to eat she didn't feel
obligated to enjoy all of the food right
there so many of us grew up as part of
the clean play Club you know and in a
lot of cases Clean Plate clubbers come
at it from a history of food insecurity
or scarcity so if this is your story you
know it's definitely worth working with
a therapy team to unpack that so being
able to confidently pack up leftovers or
leave food on our plate May simply just
be a sign of having that early childhood
food security alternatively
it may be a skinny person behavior that
signifies a healthy relationship with
food where you can honor your internal
hunger cues rather than relying on just
external ones like what is on your plate
and this in turn may help people
effortlessly manage their weight that
said I feel like it's hard to suggest
this as a tip because intentionally
forcing yourself to leave food on your
plate or like just eat half of it and
then pack up the other half to take home
like so many diet magazines have taught
us can actually further push us away
from our true hunger cues but I would
say assuming that food security is not
an issue I invite you to ask yourself
how finishing everything on your plate
is currently serving you if waste is a
concern it's worth asking yourself if
it's respecting your body to use it kind
of like a trash can alternative when our
body is saying no no I actually don't
want more this is a big topic more than
I can get into in this video but I've
actually got a cool video on filling
your fullness that has lots of great
exercises for my Clean Plate clubbers
all right I'm gonna puree this up
number three eating your dinner early it
seems like a lot of healthy people eat
dinner rather early and then after that
they're just done eating for the day so
it is true that late night eating is
associated with greater risk of weight
gain and there are a number of potential
reasons why this might be one our bodies
are more sensitive to insulin earlier on
in the day which means that we can break
down more glucose from food more
efficiently and use it as energy number
two skipping breakfast and eating most
of our calories into the evening tends
to increase our cortisol levels while
eating earlier on can help to stabilize
them three early research suggests that
eating later on increases our hunger
hormones reduces daytime energy
expenditure and favors fat storage and
for and probably most significantly most
of us aren't just eating carrot sticks
in front of the TV at 10 pm right that's
It ultimately calories are king and if
you're not in a caloric Surplus you're
not going to gain weight even if you are
eating a late dinner or a bedtime snack
not to mention if you are a person who
needs a needs a snack to get a good
place like myself you gotta honor that
hunger folks because a disrupted sleep
from Hunger is also associated with an
increase in appetite the next day and
waking over time what's more important
is trying to make balance hunger
crushing snack choices throughout the
day including in the evening or at night
you guys know me I'm not giving up my
bedtime snack moving on to Observation
number four for getting to eat literally
all my thin friends and relatives forget
to eat all the time my dad is naturally
very thin and active and all my life
he's just put bread in the toaster and
forgotten it's there he'll return hours
later in the kitchen and jovly exclaim
how he's done it again LOL okay I think
what's at the core of this observation
is that skinny people maybe aren't
constantly thinking about food all day
they perhaps on average don't have that
incessant food noise or food cheddar
that a lot of folks who struggle with
weight gain or their relationship with
food or both tend to have to must muscle
through every day to someone with food
noise the thought of just like
forgetting to eat is a complete
impossibility I actually talk a lot more
about this in my Oceanic diary series
for some food noise can be the result of
a history with dieting and for others
there may be some kind of biological
reward system disruptions going on so
this is not necessarily going to be an
easy fix for some folks that said one of
the best ways to reduce food noise is to
feed yourself regularly consistently and
adequately and that means not forgetting
to eat because when we get super busy oh
geez when we get super busy at work and
we don't take the time to eat lunch what
happens when we get home like we face
plant into that family-sized bag of lays
then we have dinner then we play ketchup
all night long as our body and our mind
can relax and realize how underfed it's
been
and as we discussed you're probably not
going to feel like getting your five to
ten veggie servings at 10 pm so this
simply does increase the risk of having
a less varied less nutritious diet if we
want to make space in our mind for
things other than our next meal we have
to make sure that our body and mind
knows that it's coming in a reasonable
time AKA don't forget to eat let's puree
again
okay number five they don't sit still
this one says simply they don't sit
still they get up move around stretch
out fidget Etc so there is actually a
scientific explanation behind this one
and it's also just further proof that
you can trust your body because it's got
your back so in short our body has all
of these built-in compensatory
mechanisms right
um that regulate our genetically
preferred weight and one of those
regulatory mechanisms is called neat
which stands for non-exercise activity
thermogenesis so these are basically
just unstructured unplanned forms of
energy expenditure so things like
fidgeting uh conscious leg tapping
spontaneous muscle contractions or just
feeling the need to like stand up for
your desk and walk around or stretch or
clean or whatever anyone who knows me
knows that I am a neat Queen and not in
the Tidy sense hashtag ADHD but research
suggests that knee feet tends to be
greater in thin people compared to obese
people now obviously it might be hard to
teach someone to just like fidget warm
but even just being more mindful to
stand or walk rather than sit throughout
the day maybe a more effective movement
strategy than intentional exercise
because a energy expenditure induced by
knee is much larger than from exercise
when measured over the day and B we
don't tend to reward ourselves with food
when we fidget or stand up versus when
we go to a one-hour boot camp bottom
line any movement is good movement
regardless of what happens on the scale
number six they don't use food as a
reward yep that's basically what she
said they don't reward themselves with
food so simple and to the point
basically it is normal and healthy to
have an emotional connection with food
so eating by our emotions sometimes
completely normal but we do see greater
chance of obesity and weight gain when
it becomes our primary coping mechanism
because when we use food as our reward
we're putting it up here on a pedestal
we also teach ourselves and our bodies
that it's not even worthy of delicious
food or adequate food unless we've
dragged ourselves through something that
we hate that's why everybody was
applauding for me at the end my guts
heart and of course that juxtaposition
is going to cause a huge dopamine Spike
when you finally do get access to
delicious foods which is basically what
happened in a lot of the infamous food
addiction research and this is likely
kind of a bit of a chicken and an egg
situation where skinny people stay
skinny not by using food as rewards but
they also maybe don't need to use it as
a reward because they generally may have
a more balanced neutral relationship
with it so again we need to build body
trust which means loosening the reins a
bit on diet rules while also coming up
with some non-food rewards so taking a
bath getting a mani pedi with your
girlfriend watching your favorite movie
buying yourself flowers you know Etc I'm
going to period of this hopefully one
more time number seven eating mindfully
food isn't a big deal they don't get as
excited over food they aren't planning
their next meal or worrying about
calories they just eat when they're
hungry and when they do they eat smaller
portions and eat slowly Okay so this
pulls together a few observations that
we've already discussed here but it also
draws on the principles of mindful
eating so eating mindfully means being
more present with our food which in turn
helps us better understand how food
makes us feel physically and also
emotionally so some strategies that we
can kind of like mix into our routine
include eliminating distractions slowing
down and taking more time to chew our
food more thoroughly as well as
periodically stopping every few minutes
or every few bites to check in with our
hunger again it can also be helpful to
bring awareness to the food that you are
eating so taking some time to like think
and notice the color and the texture and
the mouth feel and The Taste and the
smell Etc basically engaging all the
senses remember that fullness is a
combination of satiety and satisfaction
and mindful eating specifically targets
that satisfaction piece to prevent
overeating later on all right number
eight dry drinking a lot of coffee and
forgetting to eat observation I've
noticed my skinny friends that drink a
lot of coffee and they forget to eat
yeah I knew we would eventually run into
some obviously problematic observations
like I also have seen a lot of skinny
people chain smoke and forget to eat but
I'm not telling the world that that's
like a legit Health hack first of all I
love my coffee so I'm not getting on
coffee and sure as I discussed in my
video on caffeine and weight loss some
research suggests that coffee might
slightly reduce appetite but the
appetite suppressing effects are
short-lived in other words even if you
didn't eat as much for breakfast because
you just choked like a venti Americano
you are more than likely just gonna make
up for those calories later on in the
day another research has found no
difference in calorie intake after
drinking coffee so don't get hung up on
the metabolism boosting benefits of
having coffee overuse of faux energy
from caffeine in lieu of real energy for
yourselves AKA food is arguably
disorderly in my books so while skinny
people might do this it is not a healthy
or sustainable tip like coffee is life
but it's not a meal observation number
nine building balanced meals whenever I
make a meal or snack I mentally check if
it has protein carbs and fat to make
sure I'm fueling myself for longer
can we make my smile even bigger folks I
didn't know when Ivy's kitchen stubby
when I see one because this is straight
out of the HCC handbook obviously I've
discussed this in my sustainable weight
loss video here and also basically
everywhere across my channel but using
an additive approach by balancing meals
with protein fat and fiber-ish carbs can
effortlessly support sustainable weight
loss and I know this sounds kind of
counter-intuitive considering the
decades-long diet culture rhetoric that
we've been sold that suggests that you
need to eat less to weigh less which is
not untrue on a calorie level but we
will never get out of scarcity mentality
if we're constantly thinking about food
and we will never not be thinking about
food if we're hungry whether that's
physical hunger or emotional hunger so
adding rather than subtracting hunger
crushing compounds helps keep us Fuller
longer it helps prevent an eventual
binge and it helps to naturally Edge out
some of the less nutritious higher
calorie foods that typically make weight
maintenance a lot harder and tip number
10 drinking water with meals I chug this
out of water especially at restaurants
and drinking while I'm eating fills me
up a lot even when I don't eat that much
food I drink like three glasses of water
when I go out to eat it allows food to
better satiate me so this observation I
feel like can be helpful or harmful
depending on how extreme you take it
first of all despite what dye culture
has taught us for many many many many
many many years if you are hungry you're
probably not thirsty you're probably
hungry most of us know the difference
between those two Sensations that said
research does suggest that drinking some
water immediately before a meal can
reduce calorie consumption at that meal
by temporarily stretching the vagus
nerve that makes us feel full there's
also some research on middle age and
older adults that drinking water before
each meal increases overall weight loss
but research in younger people hasn't
really shown the same benefit fit and we
also don't know how well this hack Works
long term like folks don't underestimate
your body's intelligence once that water
moves through your stomach and it's
absorbed and your brain realizes you
didn't eat your body will likely try to
play catch-up and it'll be pissed so I
think that having three cups of water at
a restaurant is never a bad idea most of
us don't drink enough water to begin
with and I always recommend extra water
if there's alcohol involved and
typically restaurants do serve much
larger portions than we normally would
need anyway so a little bit of extra
water could help us slow down and eat
more mindfully but otherwise trying to
chase away hunger all day with water and
also light coffee is disorderly yes
water is important and it's key for
weight loss but we still do need to eat
well friends I hope that helped clarify
some of the most common dieting
misconceptions on the world wide web if
you want some more evidence-based weight
loss tips that are actually sustainable
I got a whole video that you can watch
right here and on that note that is all
that I have for you guys today I would
love to hear your thoughts on who or
what you'd like to see me talk about
next subscribe to the channel and I'll
see you next time on Abby's kitchen bye
foreign